table shot my name is Samuel Leeds and
I'm a property investor and in this
video I want to talk you know I don't
wanna talk I'm gonna talk because I
think it's going to be helpful to some
of you about my failures as a property
investor so in this video I'm going to
be giving my top ten there's a lot of
failures there top ten failures over the
last 11 years of me actively investing
in property and the reason I'm going to
share these is because I want to help
you guys and I don't want you to make
the same mistakes and some of these
things might make me look silly or
incompetent or whatever so you can judge
me if you like but I think in order to
succeed sometimes you have to fail and
these these mistakes that I've made of
cost me a lot of money cost me a lot of
heartache a lot of pain and I'm gonna go
through each one and hope you will
benefit from it and I hope they'll be
able to save you the pain light to go
through so the first thing is you may
know my story that a lot of the
properties that I accumulated in the
early days I put them in other people's
names so I put one in my stepdads name
and away my brother's known a few and I
naively thought that when I was at the
age or had had the ability to get the
mortgage and he just transfer them over
to me and it be easy peasy that was not
the case now I'm glad that I did at
least get them and put them in other
people's names but it was actually
really hard to move them over into my
name and it cost a lot of money at
spaces stamp duty again it was hassle it
was like a whole new purchase and that
was something that I really didn't
expect so I put it off I mean now I
every person that put our property in
their name on my behalf I have moved
them over
it was also worrying because I didn't
have contracts in place so at times even
though they were my family members I was
a bit uneasy because I had so much
equity in some of the properties and I
was thinking technically they could just
say the house is in my name
we've got no contract like I was very
very very naive I was a kid at the time
17 18 19 when I was doing this but
looking back I would have at least had a
contract
and I would have I would have set I
would have got a legal advice to
structure it in a better way maybe it
was in trust for me and it'll be just
easy so that was a big mistake number
one it cost me a lot of time and also
quite a bit of stress number two so when
I started out in property and I had
these houses and I had tenants
I used to become friends with my tenants
and I thought what a great thing
how nice that I actually get all my
tenants I'd take them out for dinners
I'd been on natey terms with my tenants
and I noticed over the years that every
time I did that pretty much every single
time
it always turned bad and what would
happen is they'd end up like not paying
their rent or they'd pay their rent late
and then it would be awkward because we
had we went out to the chip shop and had
a dinner you know so so it was all quit
and they'd sort of say ah you know
surely understand I've got some issues
I've got to some extra bills and expect
you know I hope you understand I'll pay
double next month and then it's like
actually no that's not cool but because
you've become friends and friendly it
gets really awkward so what I've learned
from that is just don't become friends
with your tenants be remain professional
of course be kind
I even now I'll get Christmas gifts or
cards or whatever but in a professional
way not in a mighty way with tenants
because it's never never worked well for
me number three and this is kind of a
similar thing still on the topic of
managing tenants and I don't know why I
kept doing this and it kept failing for
me and I kept doing it again and that is
sometimes what tenants would say to me
is they'd say hey you know how about we
won't have a management company give me
a reduced rent we don't need the middle
management company I'll just pay you
direct and I'll be a really good tenant
and if there's any issues little niggly
things around the house that need fixing
I'll fix it myself it'll save your
management save your maintenance but I
want a little bit of a cheaper rent now
the human in me was like well that makes
sense
and the businessman in me was like well
that makes sense I'm not going to be
getting phone
cause I don't after Pam management
company cut out the middleman makes
sense every time I've done it it's not
worked and what happened I actually
actually got caught out on this by the
TV they did a show on it so what the
what they they did and of course the TV
always like drama but what they did was
they and they don't like landlords or
property investors usually so they asked
me if I could go on a show a BBC show
and I was like yeah of course you know
I've got to hire I got great tenants
it's all good they said you know watch
you tenants relationship with you like I
was like brilliant of course so then
they viewed loads of my houses
interviewed loads of my tenants and of
course they found the one that was the
most drama the problem tenant the
problem issue and the problem issue and
here's what had happened so I had a
tenant nice lady she was called Marie I
can say that because it was on the BBC
show so it's public
she was called Marie she moved into one
of my houses on the basis that she'd pay
reduced we're known as what's that that
story that set up but the problem was
when there was a problem that needed to
fix in she didn't have the money to fix
it but she didn't want to tell me that
there was a problem because then she
thought I'd put a rent up so what would
happen is to be a little problem in the
house and she just leave it and you
probably know if there's a problem in
the house and you leave it what happens
as it gets worse
so this leak in the roof had just
dripped and dripped and drip she didn't
want to tell me there was no management
company because I wanted to save my
pennies and then this leak turned into a
major problem and the roof basically
caved in and then I went to the property
and it's like oh what happened so their
little 40 pound a month that I'd saved
each month now I've got to spend six
thousand pounds getting this roof
repaired and that that was the moment I
think that was like 2016 when I thought
okay from now on I'm gonna have
management companies or and every six
months I'm gonna have a feedback form
checking with the tenants make sure
there's no problems with the houses
doing inspection of some kind and I
learned the hard way so that's mistake
number three state number four
this is a bad one and that is losing AST
contracts with tenants I move house a
lot so I move house my office used to be
based at my house especially with the
property side of the business with Lee
like management's on of the business and
sometimes when I have moved house I've
lost paperwork because how often do you
need to look at an ASD contract if
you've got tenants that have lived
better at five years you don't
particularly like look at it every week
and then and then what happens is the
tenant stops paying rent and they become
a bad tenant and you want to kick them
out and you're like man where's there
are you looking through and you can't
find their AST contractor you've lost it
guess what that means bad news that
means that you are gonna really struggle
to keep them out because you've got no
contract we've done so this has happened
to me probably about ten times probably
a little more I'm ashamed to say it but
hey I've got a lot of tenants and I've
been in the business for over a decade
and it's just something that has
happened and it's every time I've gone
it's never gonna happen again and it's
happened again
also this is when it happens when you
change letting agents say when you when
your agency if you fire letting agency
and then they go bust or whatever and
then the tenant stays in there and then
you bring in a new one and they're like
where's the contract and you speak to
the agent and a lot they're either
combust or they ignore you or the fallen
out with you or you never had on like an
agent and you lose the entity contract
hold AST contracts with your life lest
you later need to rely on it to kick out
again okay number five this is the worst
this one this mistake didn't cost me any
money but it brought me so much stress
and it could have cost me everything and
that is this filing your accounts late
now listen if you file your accounts
like what's the problem maybe the
accountant
you know files them a bit late and then
you have to pay a fine or whatever no
problem
no wrong big problem massive problem
because if you've got a company that
holds properties and the company files
its account even if it's just
completion statement or whatever the
HMRC Companies House can give the
company a strike and if you still don't
realize because you don't open letters
and you change the counsel you have
sloppy accountants okay and then you and
you don't file it what they can do is
they can literally close the company
down you lose everything I'm serious
this is this is the weirdest thing I've
had it where our other company accounts
late okay and then I've had a message of
HMRC saying your company's got a strike
and if you don't do it we could
literally close the company no it's easy
to exist you lose everything and I'm
like surely not surely just by filing
your accounts like they can't take
everything from you they can never ever
let that happen to you make sure you're
on top of your accountant make sure he's
aware of all of your companies because
what I do sometimes I've set up a new
company okay I blow and he set up a new
company because I want it to ring-fence
and I'll catch these few properties and
then I've not told my accountant I know
you probably thinking now I'm terrible
person and I'm an awful incompetent
businessman listen I'm just being honest
with you and I'm telling you some of the
mistakes that I've made over the last
over a decade and that one could have
cost me almost everything don't let it
happen to you mistake number six and
this is the builders dealing with
builders when you're dealing with
builders make sure that you stick to
budgets stick to timescale get an
itemized breakdown of everything I think
the biggest mistake that I've probably
made is when I've had a project that
needs doing and I've instructed a
building company to come on do all the
works and then I've looked at the
breakdown of the bill and I thought like
you know three thousand pound for the
plumbing I'm sure that that's a bit
expensive and I've kind of stuck my nose
in a bit too much and then I've ended up
saying to them cancel that there you
know oh you want to change the fuse box
and change the electrics it's going to
cost five grand I reckon I could find
someone to do cheaper cancel that bit
and then I'll start bringing my own
freelancers in and it's just messy
because what happens is trades people
work man get in each other's way and
when you've got when you're arranging
for the plumber and
you're arranging for the electrician and
you're arranging for the plaster and
you're arranging for the painter there
is a logistical nightmare what you want
is you want one point of contact that
has their own team and they manage their
own team because other what happens is
trades people stop blaming other trades
people are oh they left this mess and
that all I can't start on that until
that's denied and they blame each other
nightmare nightmare nightmare pay a
little bit more have it or systemized
and just get it done properly he'll be
faster and ultimately it'll be cheaper
the job be done better mistake number
seven this is a really interesting one
because this one didn't come into a
little bit later in a property journey
and it kind of kind of stuffed me a
little bit that is this when you're
selling your properties and at some
point you're gonna sell your properties
not all of them but you're buying
property if you're building your
portfolio and then there's gonna be a
couple of properties a few that you
might want to sell off to buy bigger
deals some might not be performing as
well whatever you're gonna end up having
to sell properties now when I sell
property I usually use an auction
because it's just fast and it's easy and
it's seamless but this is the problem
I've had so I'm looking at what
properties to sell and I don't want to
sell a property when it's got a good
tenant in because it's got a good tenant
in and they're paying the rent and
everything swimmingly then I don't like
selling it too much
so I'll write you know I think I'll just
keep that property actually even though
it makes sense to sell it financially
because the money I'll put I like the
tenant they're paying their rent well
I'll keep it and then I don't sell it
and then what happens is I choose not to
sell it and then the tenant moves out
and then it's empty and then it's like
are the agent the Latin agent says or to
get a new tenant units been a few
thousand pounds you know usually that's
the case to just fix a few things up
which the old tenant just kind of lived
with and it was their norm but now it's
needed to change it and then you spend a
few thousand and then you get a new
tenant and there's a problem with that
new tenant
the new tenant doesn't pay their rent
and then you think I'll forget it and
you want to sell it but then when you
sell it the buyer who's an investor
probably because your properties are
usually like investment type properties
the buyer will say how long has the
tenant been in there and you'll say
three months oh and they paid the
like last month like what happens is the
property drops in price because it's not
a great tenant name and then I'm
thinking I wish I just sold it with the
good tenant in three months ago because
if you've got a good tenant and it's all
going swimmingly it makes it much easier
to sell the property and you can say hey
that tenants been in there six years
they've always paid their rent on time
they're a good tenant they parked it and
then what happens is it easy to sell and
the price is higher so don't not sell a
property just because there's a good
tenant in there sometimes that's the
best time to sell a property when it's
all going swimmingly if you've got a
property it's not performing to you well
we've got a bad tenant don't sell it
then move the tenant out put a good
tenant in and then sell it with a good
tenant assuming you're selling to
investors which usually I mistake number
eight not having cash ready so if you've
got property and you can you can
refinance it and pay really cheap like
three percent and you know you think oh
that's great what I've done in the past
is I've had money there I've had houses
paid off and I thought okay when I need
the money how can we finance and then
I'm looking at big deals I'm looking at
development and I'm thinking when the
deal comes along I'll just refinance but
then sometimes what happens is when you
don't plan properly you see something
good and you suddenly need the money
fast and you want the money fast and for
me all you do know you're doing a
development project or something and
you're in a situation where you've got
money but you can't get it fast and that
is a horrible situation to be in
and I've ended up like taking out
bridging loans joint venturing with
people on stuff and I've resented it and
I've given really good returns when I've
got the money myself and I could get the
money but because of a timing the timing
issue it's really annoying
so sometimes I could have got the money
myself if I'd have planned a bit better
so I think the lesson here a couple of
things is number one is just forecast
better so if you've got a project going
on like the castle for instance I've had
situations who have suddenly needed like
a hundred grand to spend on the castle
and I've been off man and I've not been
aware of it and then it's it gets
stressful I've got the money it's just
tied up so
forecast well for cash flow because you
can be really rich but if you haven't
forecasted well
cash flow you can still have many
worries and be stressed out for short
periods of time and then the second
thing is if you've got access to money
it's sometimes better to pull the money
out and then find the deals and the
investment opportunities ready to go as
a cash buyer rather than looking for
deals and then finding a really good
opportunity where you need to move fast
and then not having the money fast
enough and having to give away
percentages of the deal high returns so
that's something that's been been quite
recent as well this is an issue that I
have had you know to be honest I've had
these come up periodically over the last
kind of decade and I mean I've tried my
best I'm trying my best I've now got
finance managers I've got full a
full-time accountant I've got a really
good finance team but I still feel this
area is something that I could get
better at mistake number nine is doing
joint ventures with the wrong people and
and I've had this you know back in the
day I feel like I'm probably better now
than I was but back in the day for me a
joint venture was a case of what am i
bringing to the table what are they
bringing to the table and is this
win-win and whilst that's true I feel
like we need you could joint venture
with someone there's also got to be a
level of you've got to be able to trust
the person and they've got to have good
character because even if you're doing a
joint venture with someone and it's a
great deal if they're not a good person
if they're not the kind of person you'd
want to actually do business with don't
do it even if the deal is good make sure
that when you're doing a deal with
someone if you're putting money in if
they're putting money in any kind of
agreement because honestly even if you
have contracts and everything you just
don't want to be dealing with difficult
people you don't want to be dealing with
stress head so you want to be dealing
with reasonable people you want to be
dealing with people that are nice nice
people you know I'm a nice person I'm a
reasonable person if a business deal
doesn't work out I don't I don't lik sit
there licking my wounds I just said I
didn't quite go to plan no problem
everyone in a joint venture everyone's
in the same situation but sometimes when
you deal with the wrong people if even
if the deal makes more
than you thought and then the other
person's getting really greedy over the
extra money it's like calm and they
desperately just take it from me if
you're doing a joint venture with
someone make sure that the person has
got good character make sure that the
person is someone that you can really
trust and that you get on with and
number 10 this is one that's really
annoying and it irritates me even
thinking back I don't think I'm gonna
ever let this happen to me again and
that's this paying for training too late
so what I mean by that is I have many
situations where there's been a course
on something and I'm like mmm or
training program I don't want to pay the
money because I'm being tight I don't
want to spend that ten grand or whatever
it might be so I think I'll do it myself
and I'll learn myself a little bit and
then when I'm making a bit more money or
when I get a bit of money from it then
I'll put it into the training and whilst
that sounds reasonable it's actually
ridiculous because here's what happens
every time is I think I don't want to do
the training I can't quite afford it or
I'll try myself first what happens is I
end up doing it myself and I succeed and
then I get the money and I'm making good
money or I end up being a bit more
successful or whatever and then I'm like
ah I need to go back on a training
course I go on the training course and
then I just sit through the whole
program thinking I wish I'd known that
then because like a believe me so much
heartache so much money so much and some
of the deals that I turned down I'm like
oh I could have made that work some of
the deals that I took on and I lost a
little lost more than 10 grand taking
that stupid deal on so I wish looking
back and a failure of mine is doing the
training but doing it too late putting
it off when I can afford it more easily
that that's a genuine that's a genius
and again some summits some of the some
of the creeks or you are only saying
that because you want people to go in
your training programs geez I'm just
speaking from my experience a lot of my
trainings for free anyway I live in a
free crash course I run free YouTube
videos you know but I do believe in
training and I think that I'll always
i've always ended up paying more for my
mistakes than I would have done if I'd
have just got the right training because
someone said if you think training is
expensive then you should try it
and that's so true ignorance is no
excuse it's costly and you can you can
pet you can either pay for your own
mistakes or you can pay for us to learn
from somebody else who's had the same
mistake so that's my top 10 failures and
mistakes in property over the last
decade or so I hope you enjoyed the
video and I'm happy to be vulnerable I'm
happy to maybe even look a little bit a
little bit silly in order to you to save
on that pain also if you want to see
success stories of people absolutely
killing the in property I'd recommend
you do that right here and of course
don't forget to subscribe down here to
the channel smash the light burn
subscribe here so in the notification
bar